Now that we've picked the right niche and the right city, we want to figure out are
there actually people in that niche and city that are going to be willing to buy our product,
to buy our leads, right?
Because you can pick the right niche and the right city.
You could do everything correct.
You could start getting leads, but if there's no one in that city that wants to buy what
you're selling, it's not worth anything.
So what we're going to talk about is we're going to talk about who we should actually
target.
And what I mean by that is who are the people, who are the business owners that we're going
to go after when we're trying to sell these leads?
A lot of people say, I hate sales, Nick, you know, sales isn't my forte, I'm just not comfortable
doing sales.
I like the technical side and it's just, it's just not me, right?
But I'm going to, I'm going to argue and tell you this.
If you say you hate sales or you haven't had a good experience with sales or the people
that say that, they are talking to the wrong people.
Because when you are selling something that somebody wants, if you're talking to somebody
about something they want, it is a very, very, very enjoyable conversation.
So if you're somebody that's like, oh, I hate sales, or it's just not for me, or you never
had a good experience doing sales, it's because you were trying to sell something to the wrong
person, okay?
And I experienced this, I did door to door sales.
I'd go door to door to door.
And I had no idea if people on the other side of the door wanted home security systems,
I had no idea if they wanted cameras, I had no idea if they wanted door locks, I didn't
know.
With this, what we're going to do is we are only going to target people who are already
sold, people who are already paying for advertising, which is basically like them saying, they're
raising their hand saying, hey, call me, I am interested, I am paying right now with
my own dollars for leads.
And so those are the people that we're going to target.
Okay, guys, the game here is we are going to target people that are already sold.
And the telltale sign that somebody's already sold is they're already paying for advertising,
whether it's Google Ads, HomeAdvisor, Angie's List, you name it, that is a telltale sign
that they are already sold.
So what we're going to do is we're going to come up, we're going to build a list.
Before we ever build a website, before we ever spend a dollar, we are actually going
to build a list of people that are already spending money on these services.
And the reason we're going to do that is two part.
Number one is so that we know that there's a buyer in that market or multiple buyers,
number one.
But number two is when leads start coming in, we don't want to be scrambling.
We don't want leads to be going cold.
We want to have a list already in place where we can just take the lead, hit the list, and
we can get somebody on the hook, okay?
So I want to share my favorite, people that are paying for advertising.
There's different, you know, places that we're going to look and I'm going to share my favorites
in order.
Number one is my number one favorite person to target is somebody paying for Google Ads.
Number two is somebody that's paying for Home Advisor.
Number three, somebody that's paying for Angie's leads list.
I don't even know what it's called anymore.
And then after that, it's, you know, Thumbtack, Yelp, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And the reason I like Google Ads so much is because of this.
Well, first of all, number one is if somebody's paying for Google Ads and you see they're
paying for Google Ads at that very moment and you see, hey, they're paying for ads,
that means they're paying for ads right then.
And so they currently at that moment are spending money.
Whereas with Home Advisor, they could be on Home Advisor or they could be on Angie's
list listed as a business, but they have shut it off, paused it, et cetera.
So number one is I know they're paying for ads right now.
And number two is with Google Ads, what they're getting is clicks.
They're literally paying for somebody to click on their link.
They're not getting calls.
They're not paying for any of this stuff.
They're getting clicks.
And so what's cool is I can come in and say, hey, you're paying for clicks and I can get
you jobs, right?
You're paying for clicks because you want jobs.
I can get you the jobs.
Last reason why I like Google Ads so much is typically the budgets are a lot higher.
With Home Advisor, you'll see a lot of people paying 300 bucks, 200 bucks, 500 bucks.
With Google Ads, it's very, very common for people to be spending 1,000, 1,500, 2,000.
And so they're already used to paying a decent chunk of change.
So what we're going to do in this entire module is we are going to build a list of business
owners that are already sold on what we're selling.